the facebook oversight board has  reaffirmed its decision to ban former  president trump from  facebook causing lots of people to have  really really terrible legal takes  including some saying that the supreme  court should  overrule facebook's decision now a  couple of things number one  that's not a thing you can't appeal a  decision of a non-governmental body  that's not a court to the supreme court  that's just not a thing  and then number two a lot of people talk  about section 230 saying this is big  tech  and section 230 allows them to do that  that's not true the thing that allows  facebook to discriminate who is on its  platform and what  speech is on that platform is the first  amendment  you can control who talks in your house  and what speech you want to hear in your  own house  it's not section 230 it's the first  amendment so we won't be seeing these  guys  in court